il est le quatrième des cinq candidats
au congrès les républicains à faire le
déplacement dans les yvelines eric
ciotti venu présenter ses idées de
mesures pour la présidence une campagne
basée sur les valeurs de la droite être
de droite pour moi c'est à la fois
rétablir l'ordre républicain
c'est choisir qui on veut accueillir
mais c'est aussi je le dis baisser
massivement les impôts qui sont devenus
aujourd'hui insupportable pour beaucoup
de familles françaises c'est supprimé
les droits de succession c'est baisser
l'impôt sur le revenu
c'est tout cela qui est au coeur de ce
projet devancé par xavier bertrand
michel barnier valérie pécresse et eric
ciotti fait aujourd'hui figure de favori
parmi les élus et anciens élus du
territoire certains sont déjà convaincus
d'autres encore indécis d'abord sur une
question de volonté de faire ce que les
gens annoncent la deuxième chose
j'ai commencé à regarder la fidélité en
tant que militant depuis aux plus de 50
ans je pense que les gens qui ont
toujours fait partie de notre famille
politique
sont les plus à même de la représenter
j'ai choisi effectivement xavier
bertrand cela étant je tenais à venir
saluer mon ami ciotti parce qu'il défend
avec vigueur nombre de thèmes qui sont
aussi les miens et surtout il le fait
avec une campagne extrêmement assidus et
permanente j'ai l'impression que son
programme n'y a pas grand chose de
différent ce qui va jouer c'est plus la
personnalité est encore une fois
l'envisagent ire de faire le vote les
adhérents des républicains débute ce
mercredi 1er décembre le congrès se
tient le 4 décembre prochain
[Applaudissements]